what's going on guys this is rob and i
thought it'd be kind of fun to do a
video explaining throg or at least the
origin of throg the reason why i say
doing an origin is because
throgg does have appearances in marvel
comics outside of his origin
obviously but they never really amount
to much right i mean he was part of the
pet avengers which was really cool we
could do the pet avengers if you guys
want the pet avengers was amazing i
loved that line of comics it was great
but kind of covering these origins here
right to give you guys perspective on on
where all this comes from this
originally started in thor issue number
364
by walt simonsen and the origin there is
pretty simple
the whole idea behind this is that you
had something that was taking place in
asgard that was referred to
as the all thing now the all thing was a
big ceremonial event and basically it
would determine who the ruler of asgard
would be
in the absence of odin right whether he
died or went into the odin sleep or at
the time was seemingly out of the
picture whatever the case would be
and the result of this is that loki of
course being loki
wanted to be the one to rule asgard and
so in order to ensure this happens what
he ended up doing was turning thor into
a frog
and then basically banishing him to
earth and the idea was that
as long as thor was not there during the
all thing process or the all things
ceremony that loki would be chosen by
default and so the way the original
story played out was
actually really cool so the whole gift
behind this is that thor as a frog is
met by a character named puddle gold and
this is
super important because this actually
bookends into the new origin for throgg
but he's basically met by a character
named puddle gulp and is essentially
told hey
like there's a bunch of stuff popping
off we're being you know attacked by
rats and so on and so forth and thor
being honorable basically allied himself
with the other frogs and then helped to
fight off the rats but following the
defeat of the rats this led into thor
encountering the piper who was not
really a relevant villain
at all in the history of marvel comics
but he did have the ability to charm
people and animals based on the music
that he played which led to a conflict
with a bunch of alligators now
ultimately thor was able to overcome
that right he was able to overcome
this this battle with these alligators
and whatnot and then essentially made
his return
back to asgard but only after being told
that in order to
kind of begin the process of turning
himself back he had to be able to wield
his own hammer now thor had largely
figured this out this was already
something that he he for the most part
knew the issue was
trying to find where his hammer was at
and when puddle gulp told him where his
hammer was
thor or i guess throg ended up lifting
it but it's like the most adorable thing
ever
because he couldn't lift it with his own
hands right it wasn't like a mini hammer
it was the size
of mjolnir right the regular size of
mjolnir it was it was to scale and so he
literally
crouches under the handle and
pushes it for all his might and is
ultimately able to lift it and when he
does
he becomes throgg and he basically
unlike what you would expect he turns
into like a six
foot six bullfrog right like he's
enormous just like this enormous
bullfrog it's one of the craziest things
but he ends up going back to asgard of
course he defeats loki the day saved but
the difference is that instead of going
forward with him being the guy that
would rule asgard
in the instance where odin was absent he
actually hands it over to baller the
brave and so balder would be the one to
rule asgard in the instance that odin
was unavailable
this is the reason why during j michael
cerzinski's run on thor
specifically during the events that went
into like fear itself and all that kind
of stuff that thor is ultimately
banished from asgard after having killed
the serpent right like the brother of
odin that nobody really knew about
because while he was trying to destroy
the world technically he wasn't
asgardian and balder had the authority
to do that right so that was just kind
of a holdover that had gone on for quite
some time
now the other origin and the one that
you guys are most likely thinking of
when you think of
throgg as you're thinking of the
character of simon walterson obviously
the character named after walter
simonson who
create a throg but the whole gist behind
this is he hails from an alternate
reality right technically it's
designated earth 97
161 but the point behind this is that he
was a wholly different character but the
way the story is told
actually comes by way of both lockjaw
and throgs stumbling across what is
basically the mind stone and that's the
way the pet avengers worked is they were
telepathically linked through the mind
stone so they could all communicate with
each other pretty elegant and pretty fun
and the question of how it is that he
became that way
was raised by lockjaw which was really
the first indication that because they
both touched the mind stone they could
read the minds of each other that uh
that throg
basically reveals that he was a kid who
was basically a football player and what
ended up happening
is that he ended up suffering an injury
despite the expectation that he was
going to be drafted into the pro
football league right into the nfl
and so because of that he ended up
falling in love with a woman and they
were married and they had a great life
together
the downside to this is ultimately his
wife died now we never
find out what it was that killed her
instead all we know is that she just
died somewhere along the line right he's
just literally
screaming you know at her at her
gravestone uh but following this
he ended up going and seeking as many
mystics people that
had different you know supposed
abilities to talk to the dead and so on
to find some way
if you could talk to her simply just one
last time right that's all he was really
looking for
and the guy dumped all his money into it
now most of the people that he came
across were frauds right people who
could supposedly talk to the dad and it
was just reading tarot cards and then
interpreting the tarot cards in a way
that he would he might
appreciate basically cold readers is
really all they were until he came
across
a legitimate mystic right like a woman
who could quite literally commune with
his wife and while that was possible
he ended up learning that his wife
actually died with an unborn child
and so getting what it was that he
wanted he wasn't able to pay her
and so this basically led to her cursing
him as a frog now the whole idea behind
this is this bookends
into the old walt simonsen throgs story
where you end up learning that when this
guy showed up that he was basically
puddle gold now
the thing that marvel doesn't tell us
here marvel doesn't tell us how we go
from this alternate reality depiction of
this character
to this current depiction as it's shown
here he's simply just there and the
reality is
we can go with it no one cares i guess
continuity
aficionados of people who are huge on
continuity will be like well actually i
need a definitive explanation but
honestly things like this are easier if
you just accept it if you just go with
it but he ended up just basically taking
time and
you know living in the sewers of of new
york until ultimately he ended up coming
across
thor who had been transformed into a
frog by loki
now the idea is that puddle gulp working
alongside thor
trying to fight against the kingdom of
the rats and so on and so forth
basically demonstrated his worthiness
right the fact that he was
a capable warrior even if he didn't
necessarily have the ability to overcome
the rats themselves the desire to do so
the desire to win
was significant because it basically
made him into a hero the reality of this
is that puddle gulp was actually present
watching it all unfold when
thor who again had been turned into a
frog lifted his hammer and turned
himself into the six foot six frog
and so the result of this is that when
tooth nasher had
actually stepped on the uh the hammer of
thor that a little piece of the hammer
had broken off now
why that happened i mean the hammer's
almost indestructible comic book logic
go with it but with the rats basically
circling in on puddle gulp with the
intention of killing him that he ended
up picking up this little shard of the
hammer
and then it fell and hit the ground and
when that happened he was turned into
throg
and that's how you get the origin of the
modern day version of throgg
as he exists in marvel comics so again
we've got a little bit of time here so
we can continue on
uh one of the things that goes on with
the character of throgg is is that in
reality while he was an
alternate reality depiction of the
character marvel stopped treating him
that way
uh and there were a few things that went
into this one of them was that before
the events
of this kind of new version of throg
came along that you did have an
instance where basically thor had
returned to earth spent some time among
you know humans kind of hanging out with
people what not doing what he normally
does
and then being told by puddle gulp and
the other frogs that there was a
massacre going on in the sewers that was
basically the mutant massacre and that
was the way that marvel had basically
crossed thor over with issue 373
in the mutant massacre event itself
which is a really a landmark story when
it comes to the x-men right it was one
of the first major
x-men crossover events to ever happen in
the history of marvel comics if not
definitively the first
but he just kind of appeared in a few
different stories here and there there
wasn't a whole lot going on and that's
one of the things to know
about throgg is that there's not a ton
of appearances here he doesn't have his
own solo series
he's very rarely in any team-up books
there's a few that go on right as
guardians of the galaxy issues one
through seven that kid loki had
assembled a whole bunch of asgardian
misfits more or less and that like
throgg was one of them
there's not a whole lot there right and
so that's something to expect when you
go into the character if you guys want
me to cover anything or any stories
that have to do with throgg is there's
not a whole lot to cover here there's a
few
tidbits here and there and they're
largely part of existing stories for
example
we recently finished a story called pray
where throg returns which you'll find a
link to that down in the description
really a link to the thor playlist down
in the description which will
cover everything you want to know about
thor and throgg appears there right but
like he's there for a little bit
and then that's it that's usually how
his character works he appears for like
an issue or two
part way through a story or maybe he
appears you know to the conclusion of a
story but doesn't appear until a few
issues in but you don't really see a
whole lot of him right so it's just
something to be aware of but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later peace